Cáu tân hoa sát đưa tin, công việc Mera, Rùa Bú Tíc của Bá Lan, công bố các khảo sát trời sang,
Rùa Bói thì người Trung Quốc đang nổi lên như lợi trọng yêu tiền của nhiều đối tác bản gầu, nhiều tiến bộ công nghệ nhàng và chỉ vì hợp lý,
bản thảo sát cũng nhận đẹp Trung Quốc đang phát triển giám nhàng trong lý vực này, là biệt về phát lân thương mạng hoa sản phẩm.
Một ví dụ đến hình là Rùa Bói, et quốc, giói, mì ra phát triển, giờ trên đến tảng phần cướng,
như nổi truy, ngờ bộ của Trung Quốc, kết thỏa với phần biệm đổi đẹp. Sa pham này để thu xuất truy lần tại Bá Lan,
khi đời sử dụng trong các tình bộ tức tế, như sudoi đồng và thong sản.
Có các truy ra đồng bó truy bó truy bó có lượng như só sát xói sản thẩn thủ tế,
về khám nguyên tiếp cộng và ghi phy, trong khi vận bảo đam hiệu xuất cao.
Tuy nhiên, một số y đến cho sang, sử phụ thuộc vào công nghệ nước ngoài của thế đả giá thích đức dài hạn.
Đối với ngành công nghiệp châu áo.